so this comes from Abby Jenkins and kind
of the bigger question is when do you
remain open-minded and when do you stand
your ground and this is what Abby said I
struggle with the two contradicting
notions of remaining open-minded and
ever-growing versus standing up for
yourself with beliefs and opinions it's
hard for me to reconcile the two and I'd
love to know your thoughts on social
media I guess would life be simpler
without it I don't know I don't really
understand the end of it but I think the
real question is between those two
open-mindedness and stammers your
standing your ground yeah I don't see
them as necessarily contradictory mm-hmm
I think if you're if you're first of all
let's start with open-mindedness now
more than ever super important to be
open-minded I think in order to be
open-minded you have to have a healthy
dose of humility right yeah it means
setting aside whatever preconceived idea
you have about something so that you can
enter a conversation or read an article
or watch a documentary from in a more
objective point of view to understand
that you know your worldview or whatever
it is you're holding on to is can be
challenged does require some humility
right like we all like have our idea of
what the world is right and when that's
challenged can you get into a place of
openness rather than defensive miss em
hmm
and that's difficult you know it's very
difficult and right now when everything
is so heightened you know we're seeing
people clench down doubling down on
their worldview or their idea of what's
right and what's not right
so again humility is important for that
in order to be open-minded I think
reading is super important
you don't read as much as you can from
as many sources as you possibly can you
can't have conviction about a particular
issue unless you're well-read and well
first on it yeah right
and I think standing up for yourself
with beliefs and opinions requires that
you have self-awareness self
understanding and conviction on a
certain idea or point of view right so
when you can confidently say that you've
educated yourself on something you've
checked in with your value system and
you think something is right then I
think it's totally appropriate to stand
up for what you believe in
you can still remain open to other ideas
but that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
or are not allowed to speak your mind
and your truth yeah does that make sense
I think it does and by the way have you
have to apologize I was i was reading
the end of another question no it is
hard for me to reconcile the two and I'd
love to know your thoughts on remaining
open and accepting yes well trying to
also know who you are and be confident
in that I would also say to that that if
someone disagrees with you to not take
it personally I think we personalize all
these things and then we become
emotionally charged yeah right because
we think somebody is judging us or
they're trying to deconstruct the
validity of our identity or something
like that when in truth somebody has a
different idea so can you it goes back
to mindfulness too can you remain calm
let's say you're in a conversation that
starts to get heated because it's two
opposing points of view you know can you
remain calm
can you remain objective can you receive
what that person is saying without it
pushing all your buttons and making you
reactive right okay then and then yeah
can you listen like we're if anything
right now
we're experiencing a poverty of our
ability to listen right and I think with
the weaponization of social media and
the heightened you know emotional
climate that we're in with coronavirus
that's amplified by the social protests
and the unrest that we're seeing
everybody is on edge
everybody's shouting there's not a lot
of listening and honestly I fear for the
you know cohesion of our union unless we
can find a way to transcend this and as
far as I can tell the only way to do it
is through productive conversation we
have to be able to have grounded mature
productive conversations and we can't do
that unless we're able to listen and
unless we're
able to receive somebody's point of view
that may differ from our own and and and
really take that in mm-hm and validate
other people's points of view exactly
we need our six-year-olds to be able to
see a BLM sign and not freak out yeah 19
if that 60 year old has a problem with
it there are other avenues for him to
voice you know exercise his First
Amendment right it's right I have no
problem with him doing that I may
disagree with him but can we move past
the emotional aspect of this so that the
conversation becomes more productive and
puts us on a path towards repairing past
damage and recreating you know a better
more healthy union for everybody yeah
and being open minded isn't necessarily
a liberal thing or you know being open
minded and being open often people on
the far left are just as up in my are
just as close-minded this is not a
partisan thing no
[Music]